The use of digital signatures is an example of
technology to establish trust in the origin of a document.
However trust says no purely technologic solution.
Some trusted organisation ultimately must verify that entities involved in
the exchange of health information are who they claim to be.
Hospitals already do this when they credential
providers to care for patients in their institution.
Establishing trust is harder when patients become involved in adding
information to their EHR or in retrieving information from it.
Think back to how fault's support a direct email for data sharing.
How might a provider know for sure that
such an email they receive actually comes from their patient.
This problem is harder when patients receive care from multiple organizations,
each of which must trust that the other has properly validated their identity.
Because we do not have a universal patient ID here in the US,
just being sure of the identity of patients can be challenging.